in this video I'll be talking about
vitamin b1 or thiamine so vitamin b1 or
thiamine is a chemically substituted
pyrimidine ring and the thiazole ring
which is connected to each other by a
methylene reach now one of the most
important deficiency diseases associated
with vitamin b1 is berry berry so in
this video we will focus on the
structure the source says the importance
of timing as a coenzyme and also the
deficiency related diseases so stay
tuned till the end of this video let us
look at the sources where we can get
vitamin b1 so vitamin b1 can be obtained
from cereals like all kinds of cereals
milk cheese eggs beef beef liver nuts
avocado and from several kind of fruits
like pH etc now especially for the
cereals the Eliran layer contains the
vitamin b1 so for example if you buy
like whole wheat bread you buy whole
grain rice or dried east grains you
would get a lot of vitamin b1 but in
case of polished rice this all urine
layer is removed so we don't get that
much of vitamin b1 from that now there
will be one can work as a coenzyme for
many many enzymes so let us look about
look at how vitamin b1 or a format of
vitamin b1 can work like a coenzyme so
first let us take a book take an example
from pyruvate metabolism where pyruvate
is converted to acetaldehyde by the
enzyme pyruvate decarboxylase in that
enzyme our pyramid b1 is a coenzyme
actually the format is timing pyro
phosphatase now women b1 which
actually obtained from several food
sources get converted to time in
pyrophosphate is by a specific
phosphorylating enzyme and that's the
active form of the vitamin b1 now in
pyruvate decarboxylase the time the time
in pyrophosphate is the whole ring the
thulium ring is acceptor for pyruvate it
interacts with it and form our active
acetaldehyde intermediate which is
further cleaved to release the
acetaldehyde and leave the ring intact
so we now understand that how vitamin b1
can serve as a coenzyme and help in
enzyme catalysis it turns out vitamin b1
is also prevalent b1 or thiamine
pyrophosphate ace is an important
coenzyme for the enzyme trans catalyst
which is super important for the pentose
phosphate pathway and you all know that
pentose phosphate pathway is important
to generate the reduction equivalent for
the reduction type of reactions in our
body in that context vitamin b1 is super
important now if you don't know about
pentose phosphate pathway i have a
different video about it
now several enzymes like pyruvate
dehydrogenase which is important in
glycolysis like alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase which is important in kreb
cycle trans catalyst which is important
in Windows phosphate pathway all of
these enzymes has a common coenzyme
which is the timing pyro phosphatase
which is derived from vitamin b1 so in
short vitamin b1 is important for
several aspects of glucose metabolism
and we can appreciate that in conserve
deficiency glucose metabolism would be
affected now we remain b1 is also
involved in neurotransmitter production
as a part of the painters phosphate
pathway and also vitamin b1 is involving
neurotransmitter modulation and
especially for a cell choline so you can
imagine that a deficiency in vitamin b1
might lead to new riotous or neuropathy
right so when we look at the deficiency
syndromes we can keep these things in
mind
this basic function and try to
appreciate how the
officiants lead to different problems
one first problem with vitamin b1
deficiency is wet beriberi which comes
with very fast heart rate and all sort
of cardiac problems this leads to
shortness of breath and even swelling of
the legs especially the lower limbs then
comes the dry berry bitty in case of dry
berry berry the peripheral neuroticism
and I already told you that vitamin b1
is super important for neurotransmitter
modulation and neurotransmitter
abiogenesis so it's deficiency might
lead to peripheral in your itis severe
leg pain and pain in the joints and in
case of chronic situation it might lead
to paralysis as well another syndrome is
warning Akashi Korsakoff syndrome which
is also known as cerebral variable in
this particular situation several
aspects of the brain function is
affected the cerebrum might get affected
which controls our posture and balance
then the brainstem could get affected
not brain stem arrests all the cranial
nerves which are innervated in our face
and eyes so if brain stem is affected
all those innovations to our sensory
motor innovations to our eye and face
could get also affected now if the
medulla is affected then there is a
change in heart rate and breathing
because the vagus nerve is originating
from the medulla and controlling the
heart rate as well we can understand
that how severe these symptoms could be
and in case of chronic situation it
could lead to death as well now one of
the biggest problem associated with
these deficiencies alcohol abuse because
too much alcohol kind of inhibit the
enzyme attic conversion of vitamin b12
time in pyrrha phosphatase which is the
active form of this vitamin now normally
in case of the body this vitamin b1 is
actually absorbed from the duodenum
but alcoholism prevents the absorption
or uptick of
vitamin b1 in the duodenum not only that
in case of alcoholism there is a risk of
liver cirrhosis or fatty liver
so normally vitamin b1 is stored in the
liver and which cannot be stored
normally in case of the alcohol abuse
and liver cirrhosis right and thereby
the vitamin b1 availability in the blood
is reduced now daily requirement is 1.5
mg but and it can be easily obtained
from all the proper dietary sources so
if there is a deficiency first thing is
to like try to make that deficiency up
with proper intake of food and diet
second is you have to get rid of like
alcohol abuse otherwise it can really
lead to problem in your vitamin b1
levels and thereby glucose metabolism
and brain function so alcohol abuse is
absolute no-no and at the end if
everything fails there is always vitamin
b1 supplements which can be taken to
meet up the daily requirement so I hope
you enjoyed this video if you like this
video give it a thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you